so one of the things that is buried in a
lot of the ideology here
for for democrats particularly is a soft
bigotry of low expectations about
americans generally you're not capable
of making your own decisions
but specifically there is a soft bigotry
of low expectations that
attends to minority communities in the
democratic party right the same
motivating factor from people like jamal
bowman
of new york democrat of new york who
says standardized testing is racist
attends when it comes to vaccines and we
have seen a tremendous amount of vaccine
hesitancy unfortunately
in the black and hispanic community and
there's there's a wide differential
in by race in how people are are looking
at the vaccine by pole data by pole data
some 59 of white people say they
definitely will get the vaccine and
another 20
say they will probably get the vaccine
which means that grand total 79
of white americans say they definitely
will or probably will get the vaccine
okay black america only 67 of black
americans say they definitely will get
the vaccine
or probably get the vaccine and by the
way only 37 say they definitely will get
the vaccine which means
that fully 33 of black americans say
they either probably or definitely will
not
get the vaccine from compared to only 21
of white people who say they won't get
the vaccine and only 21 of hispanic
people who say they won't get the
vaccine so the black community has
tremendous
vaccine hesitancy okay that is a real
problem
and yet the answer by the left is that
that is a shortcoming
of government distribution okay that is
not correct if there is differential
behavior and different differential
viewpoints about vaccines
then that is individual behavior and yet
the idea here
is that if you are a that it's only
white i mean remember that michael moore
text right the michael moore tweet was
if you're a texan you don't deserve to
get the vaccine because you're a kova
denier
he would never say that about people who
are literally refusing to get the
vaccine
why because for him the question there
there's a soft bigotry that is inherent
in leftist thought that suggests
that if a white person makes a bad
decision it's on the white person but if
a black person makes a bad decision then
it is because the system is racist
okay that is not correct we should be
encouraging everyone to make good
decisions
this is why all of the tomfoolery about
the vaccine rollout
is a mistake we should be giving the
vaccine to anyone who will take it
at any point at this point there are
many many vaccines out there
tranching out vaccines based on quote
unquote equity is a foolhardy game
okay instead what we should be doing is
making it available to anyone who wants
one and we should be actively
encouraging people to get one not
writing op-eds in new york times like
charles blow
talking about why black people are
hesitant about vaccines but encouraging
black people to get vaccines encouraging
everybody to go get the vaccine
today and yet again there is that
generalized idea that the government
must be in complete control they must
mandate things because you can't take
care of yourself
and the but they'll only talk about a
certain type of person who is
who is covered scared or covered shy
right it's it's it's a it's a it's an
obvious point
and an ugly point but people on the left
will only talk about
covet shyness when it comes to white
americans they will not talk about covet
china's when it comes to minority
americans
even though the percentages are greater
among minority americans
i mean why you know who should be being
ripped up and down right now not greg
abbott for saying that people
should not be should not be forced to
wear masks by the centralized government
because they are capable of making their
own decisions
the people should be ripped up and down
right now are people like louis
farrakhan who's literally going out
there and telling
his millions of followers that the
coveted vaccine is a vial of death have
you seen any
media coverage of this if a if a major
conservative figure who had met with a
bunch of members of congress were out
there
literally telling people that the
coveted vaccine was a vile of death you
know that would be the front
of every single newspaper right
conservatives deny vaccine efficacy
and yet here was louis farrakhan doing
just that democratic members of congress
have met with this guy
they continue to meet with this guy have
you seen a headline about this here is
louis farrakhan who has many many
followers talking about how the cover
vaccine is a vial of death
some of these uh so-called vaccines
it's the nano particles
that men like dr
fauci have
proprietary knowledge of
that allows them to get a patent
that's right for their vial of death
i mean how is that not the headline
right i mean seriously that should be
the headline
you want to talk about overcoming covid
we should be talking about vaccine
hesitancy
by the way encouraged for months by
people like kamala harris who literally
said that she would not get a vaccine
just if trump told her to
i mean that this sort of stuff has an
actual impact
and if you look by race and ethnicity at
why people are not getting the vaccine
right
you can see the reasons why people
aren't getting the vaccine what you will
see is that among black americans
a disproportionate number of black
americans don't trust the covet 19
vaccine and a disproportionate number of
black americans
are concerned about the side effects and
they plan to wait and see
whether it is safe and yet the idea here
is that it's a problem with the
distribution system
what if it's not a problem with the
if the reason that the left wants
centralized control is because they want
control over people
then they really should be clear about
why they want control over people
because right now they tend to blame the
system whenever individual choices are
made they don't like
from people who are allies of theirs but
they blame the individual people
when there are people who they don't
like who don't believe like they do
politically speaking
this is ugly stuff the soft bigotry of
low expectations by the way completely
infuses the democratic party at this
point
you want to talk about democrat-run
cities that have soft bigotry of low
expectations this story came across my
desk
this morning from fox baltimore a
shocking discovery
out of a baltimore city high school
where project baltimore has found
hundreds of students are failing
it's a school where a student who passed
three classes
in four years three classes in four
years
not three years in four years three
classes in four years
ranks near the top half of his class
with a 0.13
grade point average tiffany franz
thought her son received his diploma
this coming june but after four years of
high school france just learned her 17
year old must start over he's been moved
back
to ninth grade he's stressed and i am
too i told him i'm probably gonna start
crying i don't know what to do
france told project baltimore why would
he do three more years in school he
didn't fail the school failed him the
school failed at their job
he didn't deserve that france's son
attends
augusta fell's savage institute of
visual arts in west baltimore his
transcripts show he's passed just three
classes in four years
placing him in ninth grade but she
didn't know that until february
she thought her oldest son was doing
well because even though he failed most
of his classes they kept promoting him
his transcript showed he failed spanish
one and algebra one was promoted to
spanish two and algebra ii he failed
english too was passed on to english
three
in his first three years at augusta
fells the student failed 22 classes and
was late or absent on 272 days
in those three years only one teacher
requested a parent conference which
france says never happened
no one from the school told france her
son was failing and not going to class
by the way he's still above half of his
class he's ranked 62nd in his class
after
after passing three classes in a grand
total of four years
half of his classmates 58 of them have a
0.13 grade point average
or lower okay how is it
that this is not considered a great
crisis in america
and what we're going to focus on woke
idiocy about canceling dr seuss but
we're not gonna focus on stuff that
actually betters people's lives
we're not gonna focus on individual
responsibility because here's the thing
individual freedom comes with individual
responsibility
we're not even gonna focus on true
systems of power that degrade
the lives of individuals nope we're
going to focus on how we can force you
to wear a mask even though that actually
is a risk assessment you yourself should
be doing
and who we should blame namely the
people of texas who we should not blame
namely people who are political allies
of democrats
people's lives actually matter and the
best way to ensure that people live
good lives is to place the individual
responsibility that comes with freedom
upon them and yet we have an entire
system that is built to do precisely the
opposite
precisely the opposite and instead we
just
keep ripping on the system keep ripping
on that system and claiming that
centralized government is going to be
the solution
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content